als oliver tschanz befragt gibt es
momente im leben wo du schon mal darüber
nachgedacht hast deinen kanal zu löschen
na klar ich bin hier mit
und ich habe sebastian in berlin besucht
mein bruder und wir werden jetzt einfach
ich habe zwar produziert etwa fragen
beantworten buck war aber klar doch rein
den fahrern sowie haben erst mal gefragt
haben befragen mit herrschte flasche war
gesteht seine und ich lasse mich da
immer gerne inspirieren
falls ihr euch wie vor kleiner von der
kamera kann da aber gut da wie ein panel
setzt sich martin setzen solange tweet
dem schwachen den pickel 8
ich glaub nicht vergessen euch nicht
besiktas wieso flasche für flasche
wie stehst du zu mir und luca das möchte
ich nicht so gerne in die öffentlichkeit
tragen und dankeschön
was ist derzeit mein lieblingslied ich
auf die frage lieblingslied schwierig
ich hab viele lieder die ich feiere
lieber nicht gut auf jeden fall ist ein
metall ist die beste rating ab von hand
der sieger der hilfsarbeiter noch mal an
wann gibt es mal wieder community flash
community clash gibt es irgendwann
wieder
ich hab ich das sage ich ja irgendwann
ich habe noch keinen genauen termin
war nicht community change wieder macht
aber es wird auf jeden fall wiederkommen
können die jetblue zwar ein
theaterprojekt machen ist nichts geplant
aber ich würde sagen der dem würde nicht
allzu großes im wege stehen also
vielleicht machen wir das irgendwann mal
vielleicht auch noch mit einem echt oder
irgendwelchen anderen blums die
balustrade ich mit so einer projektion
richtig ilias hätte ich mal wieder bock
auf eigentlich allerdings möchte ich
halt nicht nur dieses projekt zu planen
dann so sieben von sieben euro ist das
voll cool weil bauer hat einfach so
spannend ist aber so andere sachen bin
ich mir nicht ganz sicher ob ich das im
uploads hoch leute wobei es bei mir
eigentlich nur vier von sieben fächer
mindestens an drei tagen vergessen
lukas buck hat obwohl wieder seine tag
kommt was hältst du von den serien
dexter und the walking dead beide nicht
geschaut schlag mich nicht vielleicht
mache ich das irgendwann mal aber
lieblingsserie text muss übergeben habe
ich gesehen dass und walking the dog
dauert an der ofen kommt an einer war
jana weiter wie findest du lukas es
warum wird lud nicht mehr getestet von
weil ich ihn lieben aber wir können gut
info geben
jht er hatte seitdem wir das angekündigt
wenn er noch einmal lacht ich stehe ja
kann man nicht wieder treffen in
nächster zeit das glaube ich nicht
event mäßiges aber das ergibt sich meist
relativ kurzfristig also bestimmt
irgendwo
wird sich irgendwas liegst du den
crafter lieber nicht es gibt nur noch
fragen auch mein instagram die bilder
bestehen zu 90 aus mauth die menschen
auf tumblr finden oder so also zwei
typen warum machen die bisschen aus dem
velo canucks luca oder markt also es
gibt glaube ich kein problem
beide so außerdem lukas intensiv
aussieht oder was sie aber nie wir beide
dass man die fragen abschließend
vorlesen ja ok nach weiter bad bank ist
als fragt deine lieblings bezeichnet
meine lieblingsband oder künstler kaufen
konzertsaal das wissen sie aber alles an
die teils schau die videos mehr öfters
und bernd wenn die sagen möchte merkt
ihr auch in meinen blog sage ich habe
von meinen lieblingskünstlern so von dem
musiker meisten feier habe ich sogar ein
paar menschen ist dass ich ihn videos
verwendet werfers mega cool ist und
deshalb könnt ihr mich fragt dass du die
frage ist für 14 tagen wissen also wie
sieht's mit youtube dem licht aus und
was steht dem hashtag sprühflasche
geschäft definitiv an struktur und das
ganze mal so ein bisschen aufzufrischen
also ich will das alles ein bisschen
auffrischen und bisschen anderen content
bringen das steht bei mir an wie sieht
es bei dir aus die macht bis zur zeit
super mit einem ja ich hätte auch einen
link ist ein krieg schon gut
wird abgestochen oliver tschanz bezahlt
gibt es momente im leben wo du schon mal
darüber nachgedacht hast deinen kanal zu
löschen
nee also kanal löschen habe ich mir nie
in erwägung gezogen ich habe schon mal
gedacht so jack ein paar videos könntest
du mal löschen die einfach hart
behindert aber auch nicht gemacht
kanadisch noch nicht eingetroffen
nicht alle zu real
ich weiß gar nicht ob du auf schafft ist
oder nicht
aber das wird mir ja nur andreas werden
real gelbmann
die der letzten zeit habe ich nicht mehr
den drang verspürt main kanal zu waschen
was war das peinlichste moment mit
zuschauer fast schon peinlichen momente
nicht und befremdliche momente eines
premium fragt wie die b day party von
apps was ist die wirklichkeit ganze
zeigen aber die frage lautet die die b
day party von es fragezeichen so
das teil ist einfach so nice und ich sag
euch ein gesagt wäre präsentieren den
style jahr repräsentieren haben ein zwei
dorf oder lieber starker sonne mixtur
ist cool
vor ort fanden großen stadt ist für mich
so oft immer jung in einer großstadt es
so ab 30 vorort von großstädten können
dass man seine ruhe hat aber trotzdem
alles machen können
ich fühle mich dann voll unwohl dabei
bei dem gedanken dass ich irgendwann mal
alt werden und kein bock mehr darauf
habe zu feiern
ich will das gar nicht ich will
eigentlich immer bock haben zu feiern
und irgendwelche verrückten aktionen zu
machen aber jetzt dass irgendein wort
bild dass du ab mitte 30 mann im wiso
ruhiger wird oder anfang 30 davor habe
ich echt gesagt nicht angst aber ich
fühle mich nicht so wohl bei dem
gedanken ja gut aber es wäre etwas ganz
natürliches du willst dann schon lieber
stellen das ist jetzt viel besser ist
der versuch verschwunden
highlight der wertnote von activia
ferien klasse entdeckt ich hoffe die
qualität ist schwester zum verunglückten
sind in vielen herren 3 schnell frage
ich hab hunger hast du auch nur nein
kannst du nicht mal zusammen mit dustin
hoffman will zusammen longo vater sowie
die persönlich vereinigt
dem blogger com ich mache mein auto
wieder aus hätte richtig rum ja freunde
ich würde sagen dass war es von heute
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
es war ein sehr gutes video aber dafür
ein guter qualität dank 1 liga und für
die kamera ich würde sagen wir gehen
jetzt will ich fahre so langsam wieder
nach hause es ist heute noch zu haben
mit unserem macht es gut machen